SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLEY. DODD OSO. EGGMAN.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE. HURTADO.
JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN. NGUYEN.
NILO OCHOA. BOGUE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER WILK
. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO MAKE YOUR WAY TO YOUR
DESK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHAT? OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR LIMÓN. AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SENATOR LAMONT, THANK YOU. JUST
WHEN YOU SEEM TO YOURSELF
NOTHING BUT A FLIMSY WEB OF
QUESTIONS, YOU ARE GIVEN THE
QUESTIONS OF OTHERS TO HOLD IN
THE EMPTINESS OF YOUR HANDS.
SONGBIRD EGGS THAT CAN STILL
HATCH IF YOU KEEP THEM WARM.
BUTTERFLIES OPENING AND CLOSING
THEMSELVES IN YOUR PALMS.
TRUSTING YOU NOT TO INJURE THEIR
FUR. THEIR DUST. YOU ARE GIVEN
THE QUESTIONS OF OTHERS AS IF
THEY WERE ANSWERS TO ALL YOU ASK
. YES, PERHAPS THIS GIFT IS YOUR
ANSWER. GOD OF LOVE AND MERCY.
THANK YOU FOR GIFTING US WITH
THE FREEDOM TO WRESTLE WITH THE
QUESTIONS OF OUR DAY, AS WE
DISCERN HOW TO BEST MEET THE
DEEPEST NEEDS OF ALL YOUR
PEOPLE. MAY WE DO SO FROM A
STANCE OF HUMILITY AND A
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE THE
CREATIVITY OF ALL FOR THE COMMON
GOOD. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME.
AMEN. AMEN MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE. THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'LL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING FILE ITEM 69 AB 106. I
DON'T SEE SENATOR ON THE FLOOR.
SENATOR NGUYEN, ARE YOU PREPARED
? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 106 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET
BILL. SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES. AB
106 IS A BUDGET BILL. JUNIOR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES. AB 106 IS A BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR AMENDING THE 2022
AND 2023 BUDGET ACTS. THE BILL
REFLECTS THE EARLY ACTION BUDGET
AGREEMENT REACHED AMONG THE
SENATE, ASSEMBLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE BILL REDUCES
THE BUDGET SHORTFALL BY 1.6
BILLION. GENERAL FUND AND
TOGETHER WITH OTHER COMPONENTS
OF THE EARLY ACTION AGREEMENT,
PROVIDES FOR TOTAL SOLUTIONS OF
17.3 BILLION OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD. THE TOTAL EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE CONTAINS 3.6 BILLION AND
REDUCTIONS PRIMARILY TO ONE TIME
FUNDING, 5.2 BILLION IN REVENUE
AND BORROWING 5.2 BILLION AND
DELAYS AND DEFERRALS, AND 3.4
BILLION IN SHIFTS OF COST FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO OTHER STATE
FUNDS. THE BILL TAKES A
SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARDS A
BALANCED BUDGET IN JUNE, AND WE
WILL BE BALANCING THE BUDGET
OVER THE NEXT TWO MONTHS, AND IT
SHRINKS A SIZABLE AMOUNT OF THE
BUDGET SHORTFALL, ALLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION THÀNH TO FOCUS ON
THE REMAINING EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT BUDGET DECISIONS THAT
WE WILL NEED TO MAKE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM 69? HEARING AND SEEING THE
Þ. I'M SORRY, SENATOR NILO. I'M
EASILY FORGETTABLE. I KNOW, SO
TO THE SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL,
THIS CONTINUES TO AND REMAINS A
DELAY. AND DEFERRAL, STRATEGY
FOR BALANCING THE BUDGET, I CAN
ALSO, CONTINUE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
, TRANSPARENCY AND THE FACT THAT
THE 8 MILLION PEOPLE THAT OUR
CAUCUS REPRESENTS ARE COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED FROM THE DISCUSSIONS,
DISCUSSIONS THAT THE DEVELOP THE
DETAILED PROPOSALS. BUT PERHAPS
MORE IMPORTANTLY, GIVEN THE
SEVERITY OF THE BUDGET PROBLEM
WE HAVE, AND THAT IN MY OPINION,
IT IS GOING TO BECOME MORE
SEVERE AS WE MARCH TOWARD MAY
15TH, THIS IS REALLY CRISIS
BUDGETING WITH OPTIMISM, THE
DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE, IS NOT $38
BILLION AS THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO MAINTAIN FOR THE
LIFE OF ME I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
DEFINITELY, TAKES URGENCY AWAY
FROM THE PROBLEM, THE DEFICIT
THE LAO IS MUCH MORE ACCURATE.
AND I STRONGLY SUSPECT THAT
REVENUES ARE CONTINUING TO
DETERIORATE AS OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE JUST BECAME THE HIGHEST IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY. NOW, BACK IN
2009, A FEW OF US WILL REMEMBER
THAT RATHER DIFFICULT YEAR WE
WERE FACING A BUDGET SHORTFALL
IN TERMS OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE GENERAL FUND, SIMILAR TO
WHAT IT IS NOW. NOW, WE DIDN'T
HAVE AS MANY RESERVES AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE AS STRONG A CASH
POSITION, BUT AND SO IT WAS VERY
SEVERE. SO, IN FEBRUARY OF THAT
YEAR, WE'RE NOW HALFWAY THROUGH
APRIL THIS YEAR, IN FEBRUARY OF
THAT YEAR, WE GRABBED THAT
PROBLEM BY THE THROAT AND, SPENT
A WEEK IN SESSION AND ALTERED
THE CURRENT YEAR'S BUDGET. AND
AND PASSED THE NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET. WE DIDN'T WAIT TILL JUNE
30TH. NOW, WE CONTINUED TO
STRUGGLE. BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, WE HAVE BIGGER
STRUGGLES AHEAD OF US IN THE
NEXT THREE FISCAL YEARS AFTER
THIS ONE THAN WE DID BACK THEN.
WE'RE STARING AT, STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS OF 30 AVERAGE OF $30
BILLION A YEAR EACH YEAR,
ASSUMING NO FURTHER
DETERIORATION IN REVENUES,
ASSUMING ASSUMING NO, RECESSION
OR SLOWDOWN IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
AND PRUDENT BUDGETING WOULD
SUGGEST THAT ONE NOT ASSUME
THAT. SO SO, I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL. I SEE IT AS A
NON-SERIOUS APPROACH TO A BUDGET
CRISIS, AND I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
NEXT, RECOGNIZES SENATOR DALLI.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 106. I'M GOING
TO BE VERY SHORT AND BRIEF. THIS
BUDGET IS NOTHING BUT SMOKE AND
MIRRORS. BACKROOM DEALS DONE BY
THE PARTY IN CONTROL. OUR CAUCUS
HAS NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN, AND WE HAVE SOME
SERIOUS BUDGET DEFICITS IN OUT
TO THE FUTURE. THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY BE ADULTS IN THE ROOM AND
TACKLE. NOW, I KNOW THIS IS THE
FIRST OF MANY BILLS WE WILL SEE
ON THE BUDGET, BUT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS SOME SERIOUS ISSUES. WE
NEED TO GENERATE MORE REVENUES,
NOT BY TAXES, BUT BY PROMOTING
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA AND STOP
RUNNING THEM OUT. SO LET'S GET
SERIOUS. LET'S NOT JUST DO IT
WITH THE THREE PARTY AGREEMENT.
LET'S GET EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE
AND DO THE WORK FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA, THE PEOPLE I
REPRESENT 15 COUNTIES, 1.3
MILLION PEOPLE TODAY. I HEAR
FROM THEM ABOUT THE COST OF
LIVING, ELECTRICITY, HEALTH
CARE, EDUCATION, HOUSING. THOSE
ARE THE THINGS WE NEED TO TACKLE
IN CALIFORNIA. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING AB 106. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. EVERY YEAR WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND I DO CONCUR
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT, YOU
KNOW, IF WE ALL GOT IN A ROOM
AND TRIED TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE ISSUES, I THINK WE WOULD
HAVE FURTHER ACTION AND, AND,
AND MEET THE NEEDS OF THE THAT
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT. THIS BILL
HAS GOOD AND BAD IN IT. THE GOOD
IS, IS THAT THERE IS AN EARLY
ACTION TO TAKE NOTE TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE
WITH $1.6 BILLION. THAT'S VERY
SMALL COMPARED TO THE ENTIRE
DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE. AND SO BUT
THAT IS A GOOD STEP FORWARD. THE
PART I DON'T LIKE ABOUT IT IS
THAT LAST YEAR FOR OUR
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS, THERE WAS $625
MILLION. THE MCO TAX CREATED
THAT THAT I VOTED FOR AND THAT
THE PROMISE WAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS ARE
PROVIDERS WOULD GET INCREASES.
I'VE HAD MEDICAL PROVIDERS
CALLING ME URGENT CARE
PROVIDERS, AND THIS IS THE
PROBLEM THAT WE FACE. AND I JUST
WANT YOU TO RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT
OF TIMES THAT WE PUT BAND-AIDS
ON THINGS IN THIS BUILDING, BUT
WE DON'T ACTUALLY DO A ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS AND FIX THE
PROBLEM. SO BASICALLY, IF THESE
URGENT CARES FAIL BECAUSE THEY
DO A WORKUP, A PHYSICAL, A, YOU
KNOW, ALL THIS TESTING THAT THEY
DO IN THE OFFICE, AND IT TAKES
TWO HOURS TO SEE THIS PATIENT AT
WRITE THE REPORT AND THE
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS
$37 AND IT COSTS THEM 200 TO DO
THIS. THAT IS A PATHWAY TO
BANKRUPTCY. WE'VE ALREADY LOST
SEVERAL URGENT CARES ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALL OF
OUR DISTRICTS. THESE PEOPLE ARE
ENDING UP IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND THE PLANS ARE GOING TO PAY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS, OR WE AS A
STATE ARE GOING TO PAY $2,000
FOR A VISIT IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM
INSTEAD OF TO, YOU KNOW, $37 OR
$200 IN AN URGENT CARE. SO WHEN
I TALK ABOUT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, WHEN I LOOK AT THE
$625 MILLION THAT WAS PROMISED
TO INCREASE THESE RATES LAST
YEAR WHEN WE VOTED ON THIS SO
THAT PROVIDERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO STAY IN BUSINESS AND
STILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. I DON'T I DON'T LIKE THAT
PIECE, BUT I DO LIKE THE PIECE
ABOUT DOING EARLY ACTION. I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN
THIS BUILDING WHERE WE'VE TAKEN
EARLY ACTION, INSTEAD OF WAITING
FOR THE LAST MINUTE. I DON'T
THINK IT'S ENOUGH. IT'S 1.6
BILLION, BUT IT IS A GOOD START.
SO AGAIN, I ABSTAINED IN
COMMITTEE AND I'M ABSTAINING
TODAY. JUST EXPLAINING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS WHY THERE'S AN
ABSTAIN BECAUSE THERE IS
SOMETHING GOOD IN HERE, BUT
THERE IS SOMETHING BAD. BUT THE
BAD CAN BE FIXED. IT REALLY CAN
BE FIXED IF WE JUST PUT OUR
HEADS TOGETHER AND FIX IT,
BECAUSE OUR PROVIDERS, ALL OF
OUR PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE,
MAY BE NOT THE BUDGET CHAIRS
PROVIDERS WHERE THEY HAVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OR PEOPLE
WITH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
INVEST IN THEIR HOSPITALS AS
NONPROFITS. BUT ALL OF US HAVE
FAILING HOSPITALS, AND WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PRESIDENT PRO
TEM MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET AGREEMENT ON EARLY ACTION
TO BE ABLE TO SHRINK THE
SHORTFALL AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK, DELIVER A BALANCED ON TIME
BUDGET IN JUNE. AND MARK MY
WORD, THIS BODY WILL DO THAT.
AND I'M GOING TO BE CANDID,
RISING ON THIS AGREEMENT. AS YOU
KNOW, I DON'T OFTEN TALK ON THE
FLOOR. I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE HARD WORK AND DEDICATION
THAT SO MANY, SO MANY SENATORS,
SO MANY OF YOU IN THIS ROOM HAVE
POURED INTO THE SENATE'S BUDGET
EFFORTS OVER THESE PAST TWO
MONTHS. NOW I'M NOT GOING TO
DANCE AROUND THE OBVIOUS HERE
THIS MORNING. THIS IS GOING TO
BE A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR. WE'VE
BEEN SAYING IT SINCE JANUARY AND
SINCE JANUARY WE'VE SEEN THE
PROJECTED DEFICIT NUMBERS
INCREASE BY APPROXIMATELY $15
BILLION. AND IT REMAINS TO BE
SEEN WHAT THE OUTLOOK WILL BE IN
MAY. BUT MARK MY WORD, WE'RE
GOING TO BE READY. WE'RE GOING
TO BE READY TO TACKLE WHATEVER
CHALLENGE IS ADVANCED IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS. BUT
SITTING AROUND AND WRINGING OUR
HANDS DOESN'T GET THE JOB DONE
TODAY. AND THAT'S WHY EARLIER
THIS SPRING, THE SENATE, THE
SENATE RELEASED AN EARLY ACTION
PLAN TO SHRINK THE SHORTFALL.
AND IT INCLUDED INCLUDED $17
BILLION IN SOLUTIONS THROUGH
PROGRAM REDUCTIONS AND REVENUES
AND DELAYS AND DEFERRALS. NOW NO
MATTER WHAT YOU MAY HEAR ON THE
FLOOR TODAY, I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL TO LOOK AT THE FACTS
AND NOT JUST LISTEN TO OPINIONS.
HERE'S THE FACT WE FULLY EXPECT
COME MAY, WE FULLY EXPECT, COME
MAY, THE NONPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THAT WE ALL
RELY ON EACH AND EVERY DAY, AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
FORECAST THEIR FORECASTS.
THEY'RE GOING TO REFLECT THE
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
EMBEDDED IN THIS EARLY ACTION
BUDGET IN FRONT OF US. SO WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN? THIS AGREEMENT
IS GOING TO REDUCE THIS COMING
YEAR'S PROJECTED DEFICIT BY
APPROXIMATELY 71 BILLION. FULL
STOP. AND THIS IS A FACT. AND
WE'VE DONE THIS WITH FULL
TRANSPARENCY. LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE SENATE HAS DONE ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY. THE SENATE'S PLAN
WAS RELEASED ON MARCH 14TH. FULL
DETAILS ON OUR ROADMAP TO REDUCE
17 BILLION WAS RELEASED TO EVERY
MEMBER OF THIS BODY, RELEASED TO
THE PUBLIC AND RELEASED TO THE
PRESS. ALL BUDGET ITEMS HAVE
BEEN THOROUGHLY AND PUBLICLY
HEARD THROUGH THE FULL COMMITTEE
PROCESS. THIS INCLUDES TESTIMONY
FROM RESIDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, THE ADMINISTRATION,
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND JUST LAST WEEK,
BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM MEMBERS
THAT THEY WANTED ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY, JUST LAST WEEK, WE
PUT OUR ENTIRE SHRINK, THE
SHORTFALL PLAN, OUR BUDGET
AGREEMENT, ALL 20 PAGES ONLINE.
IT WAS ONLINE SO THAT EVERYONE
IN THIS BODY AND THE PUBLIC
COULD SEE HOW WE PLAN TO REDUCE
THE DEFICIT BY APPROXIMATELY $17
BILLION, KNOWING THAT WE HAVE
MORE WORK AHEAD, WE PUT FORWARD
THIS EARLY ACTION PLAN TO
PROTECT OUR PROGRESS AND
SAFEGUARD CORE PROGRAMS THAT WE
COULD SPEND TIME AND ENERGY ON.
THE MORE CHALLENGING DECISIONS
TO CLOSE THE REMAINING BUDGET
GAP RESPONSIBLY. AND WE'RE GOING
TO DO JUST THAT. I'M GOING TO
WRAP UP WITH THIS. HERE'S WHAT
YOU CAN EXPECT. YOU CAN EXPECT
MORE THAN 100 LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
HEARINGS ARE GOING TO BE HELD
THIS YEAR, 100. AND IT'S OUR
HOPE EVERYONE TUNES IN. IT'S OUR
HOPE THAT EVERYONE SHOWS UP AND
MAKES THEIR VOICE HEARD. AND
FINALLY, BUDGETS ARE A VALUE
STATEMENT. AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, NO MATTER HOW TOUGH
THE BUDGET OUTLOOK MAY BE, WE
ARE COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
OUR BUDGET, OUR BUDGET REFLECTS
OUR MOST VALUABLE ASSET. THAT'S
THE PEOPLE OF THE GOLDEN STATE.
COLLEAGUES, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT, FOR THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM AND SEEING NONE. SENATOR
WIENER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, SO I
WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
STATEMENTS FROM, MY FRIEND, THE
SENATOR FROM FAIR OAKS. THE
BUDGET VICE CHAIR, HARKENING
BACK TO 2009 AND THE SOMEHOW,
GOOD OLD DAYS OF 2009, BUT I
WILL I'M GOING TO DATE MYSELF
AND QUOTE SOME LYRICS FROM BILLY
JOEL. THE GOOD OLD DAYS WEREN'T
ALWAYS GOOD, AND LET'S LOOK
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN 2009 AND
THE SURROUNDING YEARS, A TIME
PERIOD WHEN WE HAD A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR AND WE HAD REPUBLICANS
IN THE LEGISLATURE, HAD AN
EFFECTIVE VETO OVER THE BUDGET
BECAUSE IT WAS A TWO THIRDS.
LET'S LOOK WHAT HAPPENED THEN.
IN 2009, WE PASSED A PLACEHOLDER
BUDGET. WE THE LEGISLATURE,
PASSED A PLACEHOLDER BUDGET IN
FEBRUARY, BUT DID NOT PASS THE
ACTUAL FINAL BUDGET UNTIL JULY
28TH. LATE IN 2007, THE BUDGET
WAS PASSED AUGUST 24TH. LATE
2008. THE BUDGET WAS PASSED
SEPTEMBER 23RD. LATE 2010. IT
WAS PASSED ON OCTOBER 8TH,
OCTOBER 8TH, LATE, SO I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THOSE
ACTUAL FACTS AND YOU COMPARE IT
TO WHERE WE ARE NOW SINCE
GOVERNOR BROWN TOOK OFFICE IN
2011, FOLLOWED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM, OUR BUDGET RESERVES,
WHICH WERE ZERO BACK THEN IN
THOSE GOOD OLD DAYS. AND I'M
SURE THERE ARE STAFF IN THIS
BUILDING WHO REMEMBER RECEIVING
AN IOU INSTEAD OF A PAYCHECK
BECAUSE WE HAD NO CASH FLOW. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAD NO CASH
FLOW IN THESE GOOD OLD DAYS. AND
OUR WORKERS GOT IOUS. CAN YOU
EVEN IMAGINE THAT? BUT NOW, ALL
THESE YEARS INTO GOVERNOR BROWN
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS SENATE AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE ASSEMBLY,
WE NOW HAVE OVER $30 BILLION IN
CASH RESERVES AND WE ARE, OF
COURSE, GOING TO PASS AN ON TIME
BUDGET. AND WE DON'T HAVE TO BE
TAKING THIS ACTION TODAY. WE
COULD HAVE SAID WE'RE GOING TO
JUST DO EVERYTHING IN JUNE. AND
BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THIS GOVERNOR ARE HIGHLY
RESPONSIVE AND STEWARDING
TAXPAYER RESOURCES, WE ARE NOW
REDUCING THE SHORTFALL BY $17.3
BILLION MONTHS AHEAD OF WHEN WE
HAVE TO DO IT, WHICH WILL MAKE
GIVE US THE ABILITY TO FOCUS
LIKE A LASER ON THE INCREDIBLY
HARD WORK AHEAD. AND DIFFICULT
CHOICES WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE. THE ONE THING I WILL AGREE
WITH WE HAVE A BIG DEFICIT AND
IT'S A PROBLEM, AND IT'S GOING
TO REQUIRE HARD CHOICES. WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THOSE CHOICES.
LET'S TAKE THE FIRST STEP.
TODAY, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL.
DISCUSSION. HAVING SEIZED
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILED ITEM 69. ALAN, I I'LL
RODA-GIL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLY NØ DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
HURTADO I JONES NÓ. LAIRD I
LIMÓN I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NILO. NÓ
OCHOA. PADILLA PORTANTINO I ROTH
I RUBIO I SEYARTO. NÓ SKINNER I
SMILED. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBER I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE NGUYEN NÓ.
OKOBOJI PADILLA. AGE 32. NOES
FIVE. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW.
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. AT THIS
TIME, SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
JURUPA COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT. I'VE BEEN VERY PROUD
TO REPRESENT THE CITY OF HARUPA
VALLEY IN THIS PARTICULAR
DISTRICT FOR ALMOST 12 YEARS,
AND I'M PLEASED THAT THE
DISTRICT HAS BEEN NAMED
CALIFORNIA'S WASTEWATER
COLLECTION SYSTEM OF THE YEAR.
THE STATEWIDE AWARD HONORS THE
DISTRICT'S EXCEPTIONAL
COMMITMENT TO MAINTAINING ITS
WASTEWATER COLLECTION SYSTEM.
THE DISTRICT IS NOT ONLY A MODEL
FOR SAVING SCARCE WATER
RESOURCES IN OUR STATE, BUT ALSO
A NATIONWIDE LEADER.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE DISTRICT
ARE IN SACRAMENTO TODAY TO
RECEIVE THIS WELL-DESERVED HONOR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ENVIRONMENT ASSOCIATION, AND
WITH US IN THE GALLERY ARE OUR
DISTRICT PRESIDENT, BART MORENO,
GENERAL MANAGER CHRIS BURCH, AND
MANAGER OF GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ARMAAN TARZI. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING THEM A WARM
SENATE WELCOME AND CONGRATULATE
THESE INCREDIBLE PUBLIC
SERVANTS. HOW ABOUT IT, SENATORS
?
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON THE MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ,
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. NOW IT'S
TIME FOR MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. THERE ARE NONE.
NOW, MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. MOVING ON TO
SECOND READING SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1271 WITH
AMENDMENTS 1417 1193, WITH
AMENDMENTS 1297, WITH AMENDMENTS
1022, WITH AMENDMENTS 1038, WITH
AMENDMENTS 1108, WITH AMENDMENTS
970 WITH AMENDMENTS. SECOND
READINGS READ NOW MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE
SIX ITEMS THERE. SENATOR LAIRD,
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY SENATOR
LAIRD, ARE YOU READY? I AM
READY. BUT THE FIRST ITEM THERE
WE ARE IS ITEM 24. THERE ARE SIX
INDIVIDUAL ITEMS. EACH ONE IS AN
INDIVIDUAL COMMISSIONER ON THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS. THE
FIRST ONE IS FILE ITEM 24. IT'S
THE CONFIRMATION OF ROBERT
BARTON. ROBERT BARTON FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS. HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD IN 2017.
PRIOR TO THIS ROLE, HE WAS
SERVING AS THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
CÁC CDCR. HE ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS SUPERVISING DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE KERN
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL 3RD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
I'LL BE OPPOSING ALL SIX
CANDIDATES THIS MORNING, BUT
I'LL ONLY SPEAK ONCE TO SPARE US
SOME TIME AND HELP US GET OFF
THE FLOOR. SO IF YOU ALL CAN
JUST APPLY THESE COMMENTS TO ALL
SIX VOTES, I'D APPRECIATE IT.
BUT I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARING
COMMISSIONERS THAT ARE UP FOR
CONFIRMATION TODAY. SO AS I
SAID, MY COMMENTS WILL APPLY TO
ALL SIX CONFIRMATION OVER THE
LAST THREE DECADES, WE HAVE SEEN
THE OLD BOARD OF PRISON TERMS
TRANSITION INTO TODAY'S BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS. THE TRANSITION
HAS NOT GONE WELL. IT USED TO BE
A COMMISSIONER LED AGENCY HEADED
UP BY OUR OLD COLLEAGUE JIM
NIELSEN, WHO USED TO SAY AND
QUOTING OUR SENATOR JIM NIELSEN,
UNLESS YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH
AN EARLY RELEASED INMATE MOVING
NEXT DOOR TO YOUR KIDS OR YOUR
GRANDKIDS, DON'T LET THEM OUT.
END QUOTE. TODAY'S BOARD IS
OBSESSED WITH FREEING UP BED
SPACE, CLOSING PRISONS, AND
ENSURING THE RIGHTS OF KILLERS,
RAPISTS, AND TORTURERS ARE
UPHELD. THE RELEASE VOTES ON
SOME OF THESE COMMISSIONERS ARE
NEARING 50, WHICH MEANS ALMOST
HALF THE INMATES COMING BEFORE
THEM IN THE HEARING ASKING FOR
PAROLE ARE GOING TO GET EARLY
RELEASE A CRIME VICTIMS ADVOCATE
GROUP, CRIME VICTIMS ALLIANCE,
WROTE A LETTER, WHICH I HAVE A
COPY OF. IF YOU'D LIKE A COPY, I
CAN EMAIL IT TO YOU. OPPOSING
THE CONFIRMATION OF ALL SIX
COMMISSIONERS. IT IS A VERY RAW
AND EMOTIONAL LETTER, AND GIVEN
THE SERIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES, I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY CURRENT LAW
ENACTED BY THE PEOPLE, NAMELY
MARSY'S LAW, ALLOWS CRIME
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES
UNFETTERED LATITUDE IN THEIR
TESTIMONY AGAINST RELEASING THE
KILLER RAPIST OR TORTURER OF
THEIR LOVED ONE. HOWEVER THE
STAFF AT THE BOARD IS REPORTEDLY
NOW CENSORING THE TESTIMONY AND
SUBMISSIONS BY VICTIMS. I WOULD
LIKE TO READ A PASSAGE OF THE
CVA LETTER. MR. PRESIDENT, IF I
MAY HAVE PERMISSION TO READ.
PERMISSION GRANTED. THANK YOU
SIR. WHEN REFERENCING THE STAFF
WITHHOLDING OR CENSORING
INFORMATION THAT VICTIMS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUBMIT IN OPPOSITION
TO EARLY RELEASE, THE CRIME
VICTIMS ALLIANCE SAID, QUOTE,
UNFORTUNATELY, NO BOARD
COMMISSIONER HAS SPOKEN UP
AGAINST THIS INJUSTICE AND IN
FACT, MANY POINT TO THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AS THEIR BOSS,
WHOM THEY TAKE DIRECTION FROM
MEMBERS. SOME OF US HAVE SERVED
ON SCHOOL BOARDS AND CITY
COUNCILS AND OTHER ELECTED
OFFICES. CAN YOU IMAGINE CALLING
YOUR CITY MANAGER OR YOUR
SUPERINTENDENT, OR THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF YOUR BOARD, YOUR
BOSS, AS THE DULY ELECTED MEMBER
OR APPOINTEE OF THAT BOARD?
UNBELIEVABLE IF COMMISSIONERS AT
THE BOARD SEE THE BOARD'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AS THEIR
BOSS, THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM.
SENATORS CRIME VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE LOST FAITH IN THE
BOARD, AND IT IS UP TO THE
SENATE TO RESTORE THAT FAITH,
SIMPLY RUBBER STAMPING THE
CURRENT CROP OF COMMISSIONERS
WILL FURTHER UNDERMINE THAT
FAITH. I STAND WITH CRIME
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
RECOMMEND AN OVERHAUL TO THE
BOARD AND URGE A NO VOTE ON ALL
SIX COMMISSIONERS THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. MEMBER. I WILL
ALSO ALLOW THIS TO STAND FOR ALL
SIX JUST SO WE CAN STAY
CONSISTENT. BUT I WAS ALSO IN
THAT SAME HEARING AND I JUST
WANT TO SPEAK FOR A YES VOTE FOR
ALL SIX MEMBERS WHO WE
INTERVIEWED AT LENGTH WENT OVER
THEIR BACKGROUNDS AT LENGTH, AND
I THINK THE ISSUE AND I WILL SAY
THE EVIDENCE, THE ACTUAL
CONCRETE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
THOSE GO BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
AND ARE GRANTED EARLY RELEASE.
THERE IS LESS THAN A 2%
RECIDIVISM RATE AT THIS TIME,
LESS THAN 2% RECIDIVISM RATE. SO
WE'RE DOING SOME THINGS RIGHT
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE COME BEFORE
THEY DON'T, THEY ARE NOT JUST
GRANTED ABSOLUTE RELEASE. SOME
ARE SENT BACK MULTIPLE TIMES,
MULTIPLE TIMES. IT DEPENDS ON IF
THEY'VE DONE THEIR PROGRAMS, IF
THEY HAVE SHOWN REMORSE, ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO DO
TO PROVE THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL OUTSIDE THAT IS WHAT
THESE FOLKS DO. THIS IS A FULL
TIME POSITION, A FULL TIME JOB.
THEY INTERVIEW FOUR DAYS A WEEK,
UP TO FIVE PEOPLE A DAY, A HUGE
FILES THAT ARE COMPILED FOR THEM
AND I THINK THE ONE ISSUE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, PEOPLE MAKING
DECISIONS, SOME FOLKS FROM SOME
OF THE VICTIMS GROUPS, OF COURSE
, YOU WANT TO SEE PICTURES FROM
YOUR LOVED ONE AT THAT, AT THAT,
THAT CRIME, THAT HORRIBLE CRIME
THAT MAY HAVE EXISTED 40 YEARS
AGO TO INCLUDE THOSE PICTURES.
THOSE PICTURES WERE POPPING UP.
STAFF BRAND NEW STAFF WHO WERE
TAKING SOMETHING SOMEWHERE.
WE'RE SEEING THINGS LIKE THAT.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO BE ANY EXTRA
VALUE IN THE INCLUSION OF THAT
IN THE BASIC FILE. ANY
COMMISSIONER CAN ALWAYS ASK, AND
THE COMMISSIONER HAS VERIFIED TO
US IF THEY WANT TO SEE FURTHER
THINGS, THEY HAVE FULL ACCESS TO
ALL OF THAT AND THE IDEA THAT
REFERRING TO THE CEO AS A BOSS,
I WOULD I WOULD ASK THE SENATOR
FROM SANTEE HOW MANY TIMES THAT
HE HAS TRIED TO OVERRULE ERIKA
CONTRERAS ON A DECISION. AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. SENATOR
GROVE, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M GOING TO BREAK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES. I AM SPLITTING THESE
DECISIONS BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
THEY ALL ARE SHOULD BE CONFIRMED
ON THEIR OWN MERIT. I AM
SUPPORTING THE FIRST TWO, ROBERT
BARTON AND KEVIN CHAPPELLE. SO
MY STATEMENT ON THIS WILL, WILL,
BE FOR BOTH OF THEM. I WON'T
SPEAK ON THE OTHERS, BUT I WANT
TO JUST RECOGNIZE AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTEE WAS NOT AT THE HEARING
AND WE HAD A VERY LENGTHY
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS EVIDENCE
THAT WAS BEING, WHAT WAS SO
CALLED IN THE LETTER FROM OUR
VICTIMS, WHICH WHICH WE TOOK
VERY SERIOUSLY. AND THESE
PICTURES ARE OMITTED, YOU MIGHT
GET AN AUTOPSY THAT DESCRIBES
WHAT HAPPENED, BUT THE PICTURES
ARE OMITTED. AND THE REASON WHY,
THERE'S TWO REASONS THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED MY OPINION
ABOUT THAT EVIDENCE BEING THE
PICTURE EVIDENCE BEING ASKED FOR
OR REQUESTED, INSTEAD OF JUST A
BLANKET FILE WITH PHOTOGRAPHS.
NUMBER ONE, THE PERSON THAT JUST
GOT THE JOB AND IS IN REQUIRED
TO OPEN THE MAIL, RIGHT? THAT 20
YEAR OLD OR WHATEVER HAS TO OPEN
THE MAIL AND SEE THOSE
PHOTOGRAPHS. RIGHT. THAT CREATES
TRAUMA AND OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH. THE SECOND
ISSUE IS THEY BECOME UPLOADED
INTO THE INCARCERATED PERSON OR
INMATES FILE. AND I KNOW THAT I
FEEL DIFFERENTLY A LOT THAN A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES, BUT PEOPLE
THAT GET THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS MIGHT
REALLY GET OFF ON LOOKING AT
THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS. AND I DON'T
WANT THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS TO BE IN
A PUBLIC FILE TO GO TO THE
INCARCERATED PERSON. SO WE GOT
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS ANSWERED. WE
ACTUALLY GOT I GOT A TEXT
MESSAGE REGARDING, THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THE VICTIMS AND THE
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS DON'T WANT
THOSE PHOTOS TO GO TO THE
INCARCERATED PERSON TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT AND RELIVE THEIR
WHATEVER JOY THAT THEY HAD IN
COMMITTING THAT CRIME. SO, SO I
CONFIRMED THIS, COMMISSIONER,
HIS, HIS, RELEASE RATE OR HIS
RATE THAT HE HAS ON RELEASE OR
TO, YOU KNOW, RELEASE
INDIVIDUALS BACK INTO SOCIETY
IS, YOU KNOW, FAIRLY PAR TO
OTHERS A LITTLE BIT HIGHER, BUT
NOT MUCH. BUT WHEN YOU LISTEN TO
HIS BACKGROUND AND WHAT HE DOES,
HE REALLY DOES MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS ON THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE. HE JUDGES THE PERSON FROM
WHERE THEY ARE TODAY INTO
RELEASE. AND I'M NOT ADVOCATING
TO RELEASE PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT,
YOU KNOW, READY TO BE RELEASED.
BUT BECAUSE OF THIS GUY, ROBERT
BARTON, WHO ACTUALLY IS FROM
KERN COUNTY AND WORKED IN KERN
COUNTY FOR A WHILE, AND MY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY KNOWS HIM VERY
WELL, IT REDUCES THAT RATE. NOW
WE HAVE TO COMPENSATE WITH MR.
BARTON WITH THE OTHER TWO PEOPLE
AT THE END, OR EXCUSE ME, IN THE
MIDDLE. THOSE TWO PEOPLE, WE
HAVE TO OFFSET THEIR RATE WITH
THIS PERSON'S RATE BECAUSE I
THINK THEY MAKE BAD DECISIONS.
BUT SO MY VOTES ARE MY VOTES ARE
SPLIT. I'M TWO EYES, TWO
ABSTAINS AND TWO NO'S. BUT I'LL
LET MY COMMENTS FOR RIGHT NOW
STAND FOR IN IN MY COLLEAGUE,
THE FORMER SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES, WHO IS, SPEAKING ON
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS TODAY.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
LERET, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
FOUR SPEAKERS WERE FOUR OF THE
FIVE MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AND WHAT YOU JUST
HEARD WAS THE ANIMATED DEBATE
THAT THAT HAPPENED WITH THOSE OF
US THAT WERE THERE. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE LETTER
THAT WAS REFERRED TO WAS
ACTUALLY USED AS A BASIS TO ASK
INDIVIDUAL BOARD OF PAROLE
COMMISSIONERS HOW THEY WOULD
RESPOND AND WE HAD VERY
THOUGHTFUL RESPONSES THAT I
THINK REALLY SPOKE TO THE ISSUE.
AND ONE, BOARD MEMBER THAT WAS
SINGLED OUT IN THE LETTER WITH A
BIG CONCERN WAS THE ONE WHO WE
HAD A CHART ON. ONCE YOU
CONSIDERED A CASE, YOU COULD SAY
THAT SOMEBODY WAS NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR PAROLE AGAIN FOR THREE
YEARS, FIVE YEARS, SEVEN YEARS,
TEN YEARS, 15 YEARS, IT TURNS
OUT, THE ONE THAT THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT HAD THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT COULD NOT
BE RECONSIDERED FOR 10 OR 15
YEARS. AND THE QUESTION WAS
ASKED, WHY? WHAT IS IT IN THE
CONSIDERATION OF THOSE PAROLEES
THAT MAKES YOU COME TO THAT
JUDGMENT? AND THE ANSWER WAS
BASICALLY, IF THERE WAS NO
REMORSE, IF THERE WAS NO
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR ACT, IF
THERE WAS A BELIEF THAT THIS
PERSON WOULD RETURN AGAIN AND
NOT GET IT, THEN THEY'RE GOING
TO BE THE ONES THAT DON'T GET
CONSIDERATION OF PAROLE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. AND I THOUGHT IT
WAS A GREAT HEARING, AND I
THOUGHT IT DEMONSTRATED BECAUSE
THERE WAS CONCERN OF ALL SIX.
AND I WILL APPLY THESE COMMENTS
TO ALL SIX UNLESS WE HAVE
ANOTHER ANIMATED DEBATE, IT
REALLY SHOWED THAT THEY WERE
THOUGHTFUL. THEY LOOKED AT EACH
CASE. ONE OF THE DISCUSSIONS WAS
IT TAKES HOURS AND HOURS TO
PREPARE FOR, AND THEY ALMOST
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF CASES AND WHAT THEY DO
TO GIVE THE THOUGHTFULNESS TO IT
THAT THEY WANT. BUT THEY DO. AND
SO I THOUGHT THAT I CAME AWAY
THINKING, ALL SIX ARE VERY
QUALIFIED. ALL SIX COME FROM A
DIFFERENT PLACE. ONE'S A
THERAPIST, ONE'S A FORMER
PROSECUTOR, ONE'S A FORMER,
OFFICIAL OF THE PRISON SYSTEM.
THEY ALL CAME AND BROUGHT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF EXPERTISE
TOGETHER. SO I THINK IT
RECOMMENDS THIS APPOINTMENT AND
THE NEXT FIVE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FALL ITEM 24.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NO. DODD AYE. TERRAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE OR
DARROW AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MEN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. OCHOA. BOGUE
NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
AYE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MIN. AYE PADILLA
. AYES 39. NO. SIX. THE I MEAN
I'M SORRY. AYES 33. NOES SIX.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 25.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE
ITEM 25 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
KEVIN CHAPPELL FOR REAPPOINTMENT
TO THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
HE SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE
2016. PRIOR TO THAT, HE HAD A
LONG CAREER WITH CDCR, STARTING
AS A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT
FOLSOM STATE PRISON IN 1987. HE
IS A FORMER WARDEN AT SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL 3RD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, ONCE
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATION OFF THE
FLOOR. ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT? HEARING? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 25. ALAN AYE,
I'LL RODA-GIL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. NØ. DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE AYE. MIN MIN AYE.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
NO OKOBO. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO
. AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE. SMILED.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN CALL HER AGAIN.
EGGMAN AYE. GROVE AYE. NGUYEN.
NO PADILLA. AYES 33. NO. SIX.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 26.
SENATOR LARRY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
26 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
GILBERT INFANTE FOR APPOINTMENT
TO THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
PRIOR TO THIS POSITION, HE
SERVED AS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD OF
JUVENILE HEARINGS. BEFORE THAT,
HE HAD VARIOUS POSITIONS WITH
CDC, ARES, DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE, AND HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
THIRD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT? HEARING? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. I'LL RODA-GIL
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI NØ. DODD
BARRASSO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MEN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AQUEBOGUE. NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. DODD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
PADILLA SATO. NO AYES 31. NOES
EIGHT. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 27. SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM 27. THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR KATHLEEN
O'MEARA FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS. SHE IS
A LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST, FIRST
JOINED THE BOARD IN 2021.
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS REGIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH ADMINISTRATOR FOR
CDCR. SHE ALSO SERVED AS A
PSYCHOLOGIST FOR THE NAPA SONOMA
AND SOLANO COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND FOR THE NAPA AND
ATASCADERO STATE HOSPITALS. SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL 3RD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT?
HEARING. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE, AYE. RODA-GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. I
MEAN I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO NO. AQUEBOGUE. NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. UMBER.
GÂY. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO 31 EYES 31 NOES EIGHT.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 28.
SENATOR LAIRD, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
28 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
CATHERINE PURCELL FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS PRIOR TO HER
APPOINTMENT IN 2021, SHE SERVED
AS THE PRESIDING JUDGE FOR THE
STATE BAR COURT OF CALIFORNIA.
SHE'S ALSO A FORMER KERN COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE AND DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL 3RD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT? HEARING? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE, I'LL RODA-GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
NO. NILO NO. OKOBO. NO PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. GROVE PADILLA.
SEVEN. AYES 31. NO SEVEN. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MOVING TO OUR FINAL APPOINTMENT.
FILE ITEM 29. SENATOR LAIRD, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
29 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF NEIL
SCHNEIDER FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
BEFORE HIS INITIAL APPOINTMENT,
COMMISSIONER SCHNEIDER WAS A
CAPTAIN AT THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT, WHERE HE STARTED HIS
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER AND
SERVED FROM 1983 TO 2017. HE WAS
ALSO ADJUNCT ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR, ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THE LOS
RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL 3RD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT
HEARING, SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON VOLUME
29. ALAN AYE. ALL RODA-GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MINH. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE BADYOU
. AYES 31. NO. SEVEN. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IS THERE ANY
MEMBER WISHING TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR? NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME. HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1096 1127 1408
1458 1514 1515 1516 1517 931
1024 1357 1429 SCR 69 SR 78, ECR
141 142, 144, 149, 153, 155.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN.
AYE, I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALLI.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO.
AYE. OCHOA AYE. PODIUM.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CORTEZ. AYE PADILLA.
WILK AYE. AYES 39 NOES ZERO ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AYES 39
AND NO. ZERO ON THE SPECIAL
CONSENT. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. NOW, WOULD BE THE
TIME WE HAVE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. FIRST UP IS
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT, BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON
EDUCATION WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN THE SWING SPACE,
ROOM 2100. SOMEONE WILL MEET IN
THE SWING SPACE UPON THE GERMAN
IN ROOM 2100. SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET 15 MINUTES AFTER SESSION IN
ROOM 1200. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WILL MEET IN ROOM 1215
MINUTES AFTER SESSION. SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. BUDGET SUB
NUMBER FIVE WILL MEET IN ROOM
112 UPON ADJOURNMENT.
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL MEET IN
ROOM 112. UPON ADJOURNMENT.
SENATOR BECKER, I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO ON ENERGY AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ENVIRONMENT, WILL
MEET IN ROOM 2215 MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT. SUB TWO MEET IN
ROOM 2215 MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
HOPE YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND. THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY, APRIL
15TH AT 2 P.M. THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT
WHICH TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE. WE'LL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY AT 2 P.M.